all right so listen everybody it's over
for Bernie Sanders former Vice President
Joe Biden is going to be the Democratic
nominee it may not be official for
another week it's possible Bernie
Sanders will drop out
maybe after next Tuesday's elections
maybe it will go on longer but yesterday
on our live stream as we saw the results
come in when Joe Biden won Michigan
which was essentially Bernie's last
stand I called the 2020 Democratic
primary for Joe Biden I'm going to tell
you why we'll go through all of the
numbers later we'll talk about the
implications we'll talk about people who
are furious with me for all sorts of
different stuff about the path forward
but this is the reality and I know that
there are people who are going to want
to continue doing well you know if
everyone forgets to vote other than
Bernie supporters next Tuesday then
Bernie could win every state or listen I
believe that it's over and I'm going to
tell you why there were six elections
yesterday the March 10th Democratic
primaries were Idaho Michigan Missouri
Mississippi North Dakota and Washington
okay we now have on screen for you the
polls going in and the results in Idaho
Biden was polling +4 + 1 by 5 in
Michigan Biden was polling + 22 + 1 by
15 in Missouri Biden was polling + 30 +
1 by 26 in Mississippi Biden was polling
+ 55 + 1 by 66 North Dakota we didn't
really have polling but Bernie won there
by 13 and then in Washington Biden was
polling plus 3 Bernie as of right now is
ahead by 0.2 Washington has this thing
where you just have to mail in your
ballot postmarked by Election Day
so they only have 2/3 of the vote
counted the some of the ballots are
gonna keep kind of trickling in over the
next day or two and there there is an
argument being made that people who
voted later are more likely to have
voted for Biden so it may end up
actually flipping to Biden
it may stay roughly the same but again
these are proportional delegate
allocations so Bernie and Biden will end
up with roughly the same number of
Delegates out of Washington State as a
result of these numbers from yesterday
the delegate counts
have now been updated and Joe Biden has
grown his delegate lead from 91 going
into yesterday's elections up to a 160
delegate lead over Bernie Sanders now if
you're just looking only at this you
might reasonably say why is it over
can't Bernie just overcome this delegate
deficit next Tuesday and the answer is
no again unless Joe Biden dies between
now and next Tuesday and is no longer on
the ballot I don't see how because
Tuesday March 17th the state's voting
our Arizona worth sixty seven delegates
Florida worth 219
Ellen Oy worth 155 Ohio worth 136 in
Georgia's worth 105 that's a lot of
Delegates I mean just looking I'm just
going by by sight 450 and then another
240 you're talking about nearly 700
delegates next Tuesday
Arizona Biden's leading by 13 Florida
Biden's leading by 42 Bernie is still
winning in Illinois
although the poll from Illinois is
months old at this point that could have
changed
Biden's up in Ohio oh and that apologies
Georgia is not next Tuesday it's
actually the following but also Biden
Biden winning by 10 and Ohio and 18 in
Georgia so even if Bernie was able to
win you know Illinois by 5 despite that
being old polling Biden is going to in
Florida it's gonna be combined with a
bunch of the other states this is going
to put Biden hundreds of Delegates ahead
of Bernie Sanders after next Tuesday and
then you get to Georgia where Biden is
up almost 20 points
probably more like 25 now because that's
an old poll so here's my message if
you've not voted go and vote vote for
whoever you support even if Bernie can't
win he can get more delegates and that
gives him more negotiating and
bargaining power maybe to pull Joe
Biden's eventual general election
platform to the left at this point
though I don't think I'm doing anything
for you if I continue to pretend like
it's open any this could flip this could
go the other way I believe it's time to
deal in reality we have to accept the
reality Bernie law
and one of those realities is that it's
not close in the popular vote folks Joe
Biden is leading Bernie Sanders in the
popular vote by nearly 1.5 million votes
this is a far larger margin than some
presidential elections have been decided
by so this is a big win for Joe Biden
and that's my starting point for what we
are going to discuss in the next segment
but before we do that I want to dip
around and talk about a couple of other
things I want to tell you about one of
our sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk and now breakfast has gotten
much more boring magic spoon is a new
cereal company that has discovered how
to recreate your favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar 12 grams of
protein and just three grams of net
carbs per serving they offer four
flavors based on the classics cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry plus the
variety pack which lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon dot-com slash Pakman promo code
Pakman 4 shipping